foreign
you know Ashley came into my DMs and she
sent me this question I thought it would
be great so she says this she says I'm
28 years old I'm a female who has been
saving up for baby step 3B for the last
year I make 125 000 pre-tax and I have
40 000 saved up for a down payment on my
first home in addition to a six-month
emergency fund congratulations I
recently started a relationship with a
great guy six months ago and I'm very
excited for a potential future with him
he already owns a house and is debt free
aside from his mortgage here's my
scenario do I continue renting and delay
my home purchase since marriage might be
a possibility in the next few years
that's option one option two do I end my
lease and move into his home and pay
rent to help with his mortgage
I'm gonna say no to that one and then
option three or do I buy a home in 2023
like I was planning to before I met him
and just sell it and combine our
finances if we do end up getting married
in a few years I want to make a
relationally and financially Sound
Decision I appreciate your advice this
is good Rachel a great I mean a great
question Ashley uh yes so from a b and c
definitely not B we don't suggest moving
in uh if you're not married and yeah it
gets a messy messy finances all of it
and relationships and all that so
um but would you continue renting And
Delay the home purchase or go ahead and
buy a home you know here's me I'm Rachel
this is what I would do and I I base
this off of life experience that was not
my own it was my sister's she had met a
guy and she had already been planning to
buy you know buy a house but I mean it
was still early in the relationship six
months I mean six months is pretty early
yeah and so she was like this is what I
planned to do and I have the money to do
it and she bought her house and then
they ended up getting married and he
ended up you know that became their
house now there's some things to
consider here that's not like in the
fine print like six months you know that
means a lot of different things for a
lot of different relationships right and
I don't know how much she's like
projecting like I don't know where this
relationship is and I'm very much into
like Do Your Own Thing while you're your
own person yes what would you say I
don't know that the first one is not
wrong no it's not
um yeah it's hard I mean like if you
guys actually were talking about
marriage and there was a timeline yeah
and it was like all right fall of this
year we would love to like if you know
it's coming yeah and you know it's
coming then delay it because you guys
will yeah move in but if you just love
him and you think he's great but
marriage hasn't been talked about but it
just feels like a great relationship I
would probably continue I would I would
continue to move on
um because a house ideally you keep it
for five years is kind of our rule of
thumb but listen worse comes to worse
you get married two years later maybe
you sell it and yeah you know what I
mean like it's not it's not the absolute
ends of the world so it would all be
based on your relationship Ashley so
again if you guys have a timeline in
place and you're really serious and you
know it's it he's ring shot I get like
if there was a ring involved and that
would be the Tipping Point yeah things
are moving
then I would probably pause and just say
okay let's just wait and see kind of how
this all plays out yeah uh but
if that's not the case yeah I love it
Jade keep being your own person while
you're on your own person because you
never know 25 000 income 40K saved six
month emergency fund my girl Ashley is
is killing the game right killing the
game it's so good thanks Ashley for your
question and to the point that yeah
follow us on Instagram yes and DM us
because some of these questions yeah
we're able to bring here here on the
show